I got some information for southern me  he said the trucks come to take her at 8  o'clock that's right before the show we  need to intercept that truck somehow  sneak her out of here but we can't have  an elephant of New York City  two elephants don't forget Dumbo a  cousin of mine has a cargo ship that  sails tomorrow night  bound for Bombay if you can get them to  the port I promise you I'll take them  home promised you'd go with them I miss  my land but you can keep my space thank  you but how do we get mrs. jumbo past  the pockets they control from the tower  there's no way we can get up there we'll  take a free Dumbo from the Carl seem you  two could fly out there open the gates  she still works for phantom here no sir  she  hmm Dumbo Chester  so do I open those gates it's a race to  the sea point  [Music]